Good evening, are you ready to order?
Well, first, can you tell me please, what is today's soup?
It's bean soup.
It's very good.
Okay, I'd like soup as a starter...
...and then could I have veal escalope for my main course.
Is that with salad?
With vegetables please.
Certainly, madam.
I'd like the same for my starter, please.
And then I'd like spaghetti bolognese for my main course with salad.
And you, sir?
Could I have risotto as a starter, please?
And then what is chicken amalfi?
It's our speciality.
It's chicken with tomato and mushroom sauce.
That sounds good. I'd like that, please.
Would you like something to drink?
Mary, Anna, would you like wine?
I'd love a glass of red wine.
The house wine?
Yes, that's fine, thanks.
I'd just like some sparkling water.
Okay, two glasses of the house red wine and a bottle of sparkling water, please.
Very good.
They have very good desserts here too.
The ice cream is wonderful.
Great! I love Italian ice cream.
Me too.